bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 28 février 5 milliards de francs
supplémentaires c'est la mesure
financière du plan annoncé aujourd'hui à
nantes par lepoint unissent pour réparer
tempête et marées noires au sénégal pour
la première fois une élection
présidentielle nécessitent un deuxième
tour et blanc d'henri branlant le
pouvoir du président sortant abdou diouf
le salon de l'agriculture soumis aux
pressions sécuritaire pour le cheptel et
les aliments nous avons prend les
farines composées de reste aux animaux
ou faut-il les interdire ou pas pas
moins de sept joueurs de l'équipe de
france de rugby forfait sur blessure le
jeu viril deviendrait-il trop dur 250
sculptures de papier à la maison du
japon à paris une exposition
exceptionnelle pour l'épopée des tickets
saga japonaise où l'on retrouve les
subprime notamment deux mois après la
marée noire de l'erika et les tempêtes
les attentes des pêcheurs et
ostréiculteurs comme celle des
agriculteurs reste très forte cela s'est
vu aujourd'hui à nantes où des barques
de pêche ont brûlé dans un concert de
sirènes et de tambours
tout cela pour se faire entendre du
premier ministre venu présider un
conseil interministériel d'aménagement
et de développement du territoire et
concrétiser les mesures extrêmement
significative du gouvernement selon les
propos mêmes de monsieur jospin
reportage alban nicosie et patrick
berche mais coeur les incidents ont
débuté au moment où lionel jospin
achever sa conférence de presse
barrière enfoncé jets de cailloux de
cocktails molotov le tout à 50 mètres de
la préfecture transformée en camp
retranché
pourtant dans l'adversité lionel jospin
voulez afficher sa sérénité
n'ayant rien changé au programme d'une
journée volontairement sobre tout juste
note-t-on l'importance du dispositif
policier autour de la préfecture à
distance alors raisonnable plusieurs
centaines d'ostréiculteurs de pêcheurs
expriment leur désarroi tandis qu'une
délégation est reçue par le premier
ministre lionel jospin reconnaît que
c'est l'action citoyenne de tous les
professionnels de tous les citoyens du
littoral qui a permis compris à son
gouvernement de faire payer à w ce
talent
nous estimons ce n'est pas assez il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin
cette pression populaire le gouvernement
estime l'avoir entendu 12 ministres
accompagnent lionel jospin a nantes les
sommes débloquées sont importantes
l'objectif est d' effacer l'impression
de cafouillages de la fin décembre et de
calmer l'inquiétude des
socioprofessionnels le gouvernement de
façon régulière complète son dispositif
tient compte de ce qui lui est dit
notamment par le dialogue avec les
socioprofessionnels qui sont souvent
extrêmement précieux donc ce
gouvernement ils se mobilisent
il y le engage toute son énergie
mobilise l'administration et nous avons
agi vite
des arguments qui n'ont pas convaincu
une partie des manifestants qui semble
s'être déplacé uniquement avec la
volonté d'en découdre
il ya quelques minutes les membres du
gouvernement et le premier ministre
lionel jospin ont quitté cette même
préfecture par une autre porte derrière
moi il reste deux à trois cents
manifestants dans un face à face tendu
avec les forces de l'ordre
il y aura donc cinq milliards de francs
supplémentaires dont 1 milliard pour la
seule année 2000 pour effacer les traces
des tempêtes de la marée noire c'est un
effort qui s'ajoute aux mesures déjà
arrêtées les 12 janvier 4 février
dernier auquel il faut joindre
l'augmentation des moyens du mystère
l'environnement hélène vers une détail
de tout cela maintenant plus de deux
mois après le naufrage de l'erika et les
deux tempêtes le gouvernement jospin
vient en aide aux régions sinistrées
une enveloppe d'un milliard de francs
pour cette
année 2001 milliards destiné à
réhabiliter le littoral atlantique et à
restaurer la faune et la flore
l'aide gouvernementale profite également
au secteur touristique 350 millions de
francs
il faut rappeler que plus de 1000
camping et des équipements ont été
totalement détruits le deuxième volet de
mesures concerne le naufrage de l'erika
les contrôler les navires seront forcés
pour cela le nombre d'inspecteurs des
affaires maritimes et doublé de 56 il
passera à 112 enfin et c'est nouveau les
ports français ont désormais pour
obligation d'accueillir les navires en
difficulté des navires qui comme l'erika
présenterait en réel danger pour
l'environnement
au total le gouvernement aura consacré
16 milliards de francs ou conséquence
des tempêté de la marée noire
le chef du gouvernement à nantes à
écouter de nombreux témoignages d'élus
locaux directement confronté aux effets
de la marée noire sur les plages du
littoral le nettoyage continuent de
nouvelles nappes de nouvelles boulettes
de fioul échappée de l'erika et chaque
jour et l'on mesure déjà les
conséquences de cette pollution sur le
tourisme et sur le commerce ostréicole
reportage à etel et sur les côtes du
morbihan avec audition christian pollet
le soleil qui brillait sur la bretagne
aujourd'hui ne pouvait occulter les
faits jour après jour
il faut continuer à démazouter le
littoral soulier ici ce sont des
chasseurs alpins de chambéry nettoie les
rochers fier de faire jouer la
solidarité nationale moi je suis breton
donc davantage justien puis avec les
gammes ça se passe bien chambéry
participer la savoie participe non plus
c'est bien toi à quelques kilomètres de
là une plage à peu près nettoyer mais
qu'importe en termes d'image le mal est
déjà fait et dans ce camping qui doit
rouvrir ses portes dans un mois
l'inquiétude grandit devant la chute des
réservations
on a beaucoup de beaucoup moins de
demandes de documentation ou 50% moins
par rapport aux autres années
et puis moi chaque coup téléphone les
gens demandent l'état de la plage ce que
vous leur répondez que la plage nettoyée
qu'elle est propre et puis qu'il faut
qu'ils viennent voir cercle mais les
plus inquiets ce sont les professionnels
de la mer et en particulier les
ostréiculteurs les
vendre s'effondre alors que dans
l'immense majorité des cas les huîtres
n'ont pas été touchés par la marée noire
mais le préjudice est d'autant plus
difficile à chiffrer qu'il s'étalera
sans doute sur de longs noirs en eux
reprochent de ne pas avoir rempli des
dossiers fipol et on attend évidemment
que dans le temps on a trois ans pour
remplir un dossier les dossiers people
on voudrait les avoir rempli avant que
le mal soit terminé évidemment on peut
pas deviner ce qui va nous arriver dans
dans un mois dans six mois ou dans un an
bénévoles élus professionnels du
tourisme ou de la mer tous s'accordent
néanmoins sur deux exigences d'abord que
l'état organise le pompage rapide de
l'erika et surtout que les pouvoirs
publics prennent enfin les décisions
nécessaires pour éviter que d'autres
navires poubelles ne vienne souiller le
littoral français
voilà jossinet à cet ouvrage aux
éditions de l'a7 cet ouvrage où l'on
retrouve une centaine de dessinateurs de
presse sans crayon pour effacer la marée
noire
plus jamais ça est ce qui trait c'est en
vente à partir de demain au profit de
villes sinistrées d'associations de
défense de l'environnement pour éviter
d'autres marées noires parmi les mesures
gouvernementales révélé aujourd'hui à
nantes on en parlait il ya un instant
avec hélène berne
il y à l'embauché de personnel de
contrôle les normes de sécurité non
respectées un certain laisser-aller des
équipements le manque de qualification
des équipages ou des imprudences lié aux
pressions économiques sont souvent à
l'origine de ces catastrophes maritimes
patrick fandio à laurent chemla ont
accompagné une patrouille des affaires
maritimes dans la manche
dans l'une de leurs opérations de
surveillance
c'est une silhouette familière dans la
manche
letourneux pierre vedette de la
direction des affaires maritimes en
patrouille à bord
cet homme d'équipage leur mission
détecter tous les bateaux suspects ou
dangereux à seulement 60 kilomètres des
côtes françaises
nous sommes dans le rail des casquets
une zone où transitent près de 300
bateaux par jour
tous ne souhaite pas être identifié ce
navire russe intrigue
il refuse de répondre aux appels radio
alors ce serait un cargo je pense c'est
un cadeau le plus tôt un minéralier un
petit minéralier d'une centaine de
mètres
ils ne connaissent ni la nature de la
cargaison ni les tarifs dynamiques et il
est marqué sur les canots de sauvetage
mais n'arrive pas à le lire on ne sait
jamais si un bateau qui tout rouillé et
en bon état
vraiment tout cas qu'ils ont une culture
rapidement c'est un mauvais état donc on
ne sait pas qu'on ne sait pas comment
faire pour savoir quelle va tout le
temps mon état
à l'avenir ces informations sous le
pedigree des bateaux se trouveront ici
oui des forces pour tout bien celle de
la manche
ce sera dans quelques années le siège
d'une importante base de données
informatiques sur la sécurité des
navires que l'on va pouvoir les croiser
et avoir le suivi d'un navire qui
changerait le nom à chaque voyage ou
qu'ils changeraient de sociétés
d'armement fin de compagnie à chaque
voyage les responsables du projet
promettent rien de moins qu'une nouvelle
ère de la surveillance de la navigation
maritime promenade fluviale pour le
président jacques chirac qui est arrivé
aujourd'hui en visite officielle aux
pays bas où il séjournera jusqu'à demain
après quelques années de relations
difficiles voire d'incompréhension entre
la france et le royaume de landes
monsieur chirac entend ainsi renouer le
dialogue dans la perspective de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne et ce à compter du 1er
juillet prochain est bien sûr amsterdam
comme à la haye la capitale on a guetté
officieusement tout ce qui pouvait être
dit après les incidents de l'université
de bir zeït en israël où se trouvait
samedi le premier ministre lionel jospin
que pense et on dans l'entourage de
jacques chirac de l'attitude du premier
ministre
on en a parlé à la salle rond à mots
couverts plutôt découvert si je
comprends bien oui tout à fait alors il
ya ce qu'on dit et il ya ce qu'on ne dit
pas ce qu'on dit est bien c'est qu'on
est navré de voir le premier mise la
france quel qu'il soit qu'il soit ou non
de notre camp se faire humilier sous une
pluie de pierres à bir zeït et l'on
souhaite réparer les dégâts et c'est
pour réparer les dégâts que le président
souhaitait voir le premier ministre le
plus rapidement possible lorsque on dit
aussi c'est qu'on est mécontent très
mécontents même que le premier ministre
ne se soit pas empressé de répondre à
cette invitation pour ne pas dire à
cette convocation
alors ce qu'on ne dit pas mais qui se
voit tellement qu'on n'a pas besoin de
le dire c'est qu'on est au fond pas
mécontent et c'est même un euphémisme on
pourrait dire qu on jubile de voir le
premier ministre s'est pris ainsi les
pieds dans le tapis et qui plus est dans
un domaine la politique étrangère qui
est le domaine supposé réservé du
président de la république alors
naturellement on exploitera au maximum
et sans état d'âme même s'il on
vrai demain en havre et pour l'image de
la france on exploitera cette bévue
questions supplémentaires alain de
chalvron hubert védrine le ministre de
l'ined jospin aux côtés de jacques
chirac
c'est d'après très simple pour lui non
c'est une position certainement
inconfortable il est un peu comme une
tranche de jambon au milieu d'un
sandwich d'une part il doit travailler
avec le président il travaille bien avec
d'autres pas et tire sa légitimité du
premier ministre qui l'a nommé alors
bien sûr il faut gérer cette situation
hubert védrine a l'habitude
il a l'habitude d'être un peu manipulée
par l'elysée qui essayent de l'attirer
dans son camp alors il a déjà géré ça
dans le passé et cette fois ci cela va
dépendre de l'ampleur de la récupération
en termes de politique intérieure que
cela va voir on le saura demain à
l'assemblée
mais s'il doit choisir son camp eh bien
je crois que ce choix sera vite fait ce
sera celui du premier ministre
merci alain allard outre ces échanges un
peu polémique qui lie à le débat sur la
conduite de la politique étrangère de la
france
faux souvenirs que du temps du général
de gaulle c'était le domaine réservé du
président mais c'est françois mitterrand
qui inventa la formule domaine partagé
lors d'une première cohabitation
reportage laurent hakim arnaud goûtait
berne a ronflé frédéric basket avec les
réactions politiques de droite et de
gauche
inventée pour de gaulle au début des
années 60 la notion de domaine réservé
n'a en fait aucune existence formelle
certes depuis 86 les cohabitations
successives ont mis en évidence
l'importance d'une politique étrangère
concertée entre le chef de l'état et son
premier ministre mais en épluchant les
textes on en apprend guère plus le
président de la république veille au
respect de la constitution peut-on lire
dans la loi fondamentale
il est le garant de l'indépendance
nationale de l'intégrité du territoire
et du respect des traités
le texte n'est guère plus précis
s'agissant du premier ministre son
gouvernement détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation dit l'article 20
aucune trace donc de domaine réservés
l'expression a fait fortune mais elle
n'a aucun contenu constitutionnel précis
s'il faut chercher dans la constitution
où l'on trouve les
ce pression ou même le concept de
domaine réservés la quête sera ville la
politique étrangère concertée et dont au
moins discordantes lorsqu'elle est
conduite de concert par le président et
son premier ministre comme ici avec
l'allemand gerhard schröder ou avec le
britannique tony blair
elle connaît aussi ses dissonances du
moins dans la coulisse comme lors de
cette initiative de jacques chirac en
novembre dernier déroulant le tapis
rouge aux fils d'hafez el-assad
successeur présumé du président syrien
ou encore le mois suivant lors du coup
d'état en côte d'ivoire on prêtait à
l'elysée à matignon des appréciations
contrastés sur la légalité républicaine
du nouveau pouvoir
à droite on estime que l'essentiel c'est
d'éviter la cacophonie participation des
premiers certaines simplement l'intérêt
de notre pays c'est de parler d'une
seule voix sur la scène internationale
les socialistes revendiquent eux le
droit d'interprétation du premier
ministre donc il n'ya pas de liberté à
prendre du côté de la politique
étrangère dans son inspiration qui est
défini en commun avec le président de la
république mais il ya une liberté à
prendre par rapport à l'expression à la
défense de cette politique étrangère
c'est ce qu'a fait lunel jospin demain
lionel jospin s'expliquera à l'assemblée
nationale le lendemain avant le conseil
des ministres le chef de l'état et le
premier ministre se retrouveront en tête
à tête à l'elysée à beyrouth ce matin le
vice président du sénat français le
sénateur rpr gérard larcher apporter un
message de jacques chirac au président
libanais emile lahoud un message où il
est dit qu'il n'y a pas de changement à
l'égard du liban et du proche-orient de
plus monsieur chirac a téléphoné à
l'ancien premier ministre rafic hariri
pour lui confirmer que la position de la
france n'avait pas changé et ne
changerait pas il n'empêche que les
manifestations à baalbeck au liban le
chiffre est né à naplouse ici ont
rassemblé plusieurs milliers de
personnes protestant contre les propos
monsieur jospin sur les actes
terroristes vu s vaut la fin de citation
de plus en cisjordanie d'autres
manifestants ont conspué le chef du
gouvernement français police israélienne
a riposté procédant à quelques
arrestations
notre correspondant permanent jérusalem
charles enderlin avec alone grego est
retourné à l'université palestinienne de
bir zeït là où se sont produits les
incidents les cours sont suspendus et
dans ce foyer d'une
nazisme palestiniens le conseil
d'université siège en permanence le
campus de l'université est désert les
cours sont suspendus depuis samedi et ce
jusqu'à demain voici l'institut de droit
où lionel jospin a pris la parole la
france a offert deux millions de francs
pour sa construction
c'est en empruntant cet escalier que le
premier ministre a été attaqué le
professeur camille mansour anciennes y
l'état de droit aux futurs juges
palestiniens en est encore ce socle
toutes les diversités et désolé
personnellement je suis bien sûr les
présidents d'université de conseils
lançant des étudiants l'ensemble du
corps professoral n'arrive pas à
comprendre ce qui s'est passé quelque
chose qui a des génériques n'était pas
du tout qu'on peut on ne pouvait pas du
tout s'attendre bill gates est un des
foyers du nationalisme palestinien
pendant les quatre années de l'intifada
l'université a été fermé par les
autorités israéliennes
les courses se déroulaient
clandestinement à ramallah
toutes les organisations palestiniennes
sont représentés ici
elles recrutent et manifeste
régulièrement mais bir zeït c'est aussi
le processus de paix avec israël
la plupart des membres de la délégation
palestinienne à la conférence de madrid
en venant alors aujourd'hui bir zeït
entend conserver sa réputation le
conseil de l'université a décidé que
tous les étudiants qui ont attaqué
monsieur jospin seront expulsés est ce
qu'on a découvert à travers cette visite
la phénomène de violence c'est en train
d'augmenter la frustration ses profondes
et c'est pas seulement vis-à-vis les
déclarations c'est quelque chose qui est
reflété dans les comportements
quotidiens des palestiniens de fait avec
le blocage du processus de paix
l'agitation 70 dans la rue palestinienne
au sénégal pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de ce pays depuis son
indépendance il faudra un second tour
pour élire le président de la république
après léopold sédar senghor abdou diouf
semblait régner sans partage avec
l'appui du parti socialiste sénégalais
mais il est à l'issue du premier tour
hier en ballottage reportage de nos
correspondants permanents
eric monier hergé motte il est 14h cet
après midi au directoire du parti
socialiste sénégalais
nous nous étions fixés comme objectif de
réaliser de faire élire le plus rapide
dès le premier tour aujourd'hui à
l'heure où joue panne
l'état n'a ne semble pas être
enfin voilà le parti au pouvoir depuis
l'indépendance n'a pas attendu que
tombent tous les résultats pour
l'admettre
abdou diouf le président sortant n'a pas
réalisé les performances des trois
élections précédentes il y aura un
deuxième tour
une première au sénégal ce matin déjà la
rue de dakar prévoyait cette nouvelle
échéance avec une certaine satisfaction
dans la capitale l'opposition arrive
largement en tête dans trois semaines
c'est donc maître abdoulaye wade
opposant historique et cinq fois
candidat qui affrontera abdou diouf dans
le duel final
mais dès aujourd'hui tous les regards se
tournent vers un troisième homme
moustapha niasse ancien ministre
dissident du ps candidat malheureux est
désormais faisons d'euros je souhaite
que l'utilisation des canons de la
démocratie sénégalaise puisqu'au lieu au
changement changement du système
politique
changement de mode d'administration de
bonne gouvernance donc du sénégal et
puis comme tous nos grands équilibres
qui sont nécessaires pour lutter contre
la grande pauvreté qui sévit dans notre
pays un changement ça veut dire son
diouf
tout à fait c'est sans équivoque ses
seins nus sans équivoque c'est désormais
aux hommes politiques sénégalais
d'occuper la scène en tentant de montrer
qu'il tient autant que les électeurs à
la démocratie arrivé cet après midi à
grozny la capitale tchétchène d'un
représentant du conseil de l'europe
chargé des droits de l'homme il doit se
rendre dans les camps dit de filtration
selon les russes et tenter de réunir des
preuves sur des exactions et atrocités
dont sont accusés des soldats de l'armée
russe
toutes choses nier imperturbablement par
moscou qui a même organisé une visite du
camp de churn kosovo symbole des
soupçons de crimes contre l'humanité
lancée par des organisations
internationales mais aussi les familles
tchétchènes
voyez le reportage de sergei besco
ravony et tatiana tarasenko va avec les
commentaires de gilles rabin
jarno kosovo c'est un ancien camp de
travail de l'époque soviétique
d'où l'aspect extérieur
et les voies ferrées les russes l'ont
transformé en ce que dans l'armée on
appelle un isolateur les tchétchènes eux
disent qu'en de filtration la première
visite du camp autorisé pour la presse
étrangère est très encadrée un général
un procureur militaire et la peinture
des couloirs toute fraîche qui collent
encore aux mains d'après les russes le
représentant du conseil de l'europe pour
les droits de l'homme a fait la même
visite y est sorti en vitesse
gérez vous les autres partent à la
promenade lui reste qu elle en aura pas
le temps de lui demander de quoi il
souffre ils sont venus chez moi le 26
janvier entre autres de pastor le mien
était en rêvent mais ils ont dit qu'on
devait l'enregistrer de nouveau et
depuis je suis ici qui est pas meilleure
avec les représentants de droits de
l'homme
moi j'ai parlé
qu'est ce que vous leur avez dit comment
vit ce qu'on mange
qu'est-ce que vous avez répondu la même
chose que les autres
vous avez peur ici il est possible
d'avoir peur ici aujourd'hui il y avait
cinquante prisonniers à thierno cause au
bout celle-ci à 53 ans elle a été
arrêtée il ya un mois parce qu'elle
portait un pantalon de miliciens des
chaussures de soldats les russes
l'accusent d'avoir été sleeper tireuse
d'élite termites en histoire maintenant
on ne vous a rien caché
il n'y a pas de salle de torture ici il
n'y a absolument rien contre les droits
de l'homme
m
vas-y vas-y ne t'arrête pas à la sortie
du camp les femmes mères filles épouses
de prisonniers voulait parler aux
journalistes étrangers
le bus ne s'est pas arrêtée et l'armée a
interdit aux journalistes de descendre
les écouter
roland dumas pourrait quitter ses
fonctions de président du conseil
constitutionnel et l'annoncer d'ici
mercredi la rencontre et ce matin la
présidente par intérim du conseil
constitutionnel yves guéna ainsi que
l'un des membres de ce conseil pierre
mazeaud à rodez devant les jurés de la
cour d'assises de l'aveyron les
témoignages qui se succèdent conforte
des accusations de viol et d'agressions
sexuelles sur mineures accusations pour
lesquelles l'abbé jean lucien morel
comparer mais l'abbé continue de nier
ces faits criminels
compte rendu d'audience avec 2 minutes
vers veilhan et blaise grenier une
longue attente non récompensés venus
nombreux partisans et opposants de la
baie morel n'ont pu entendre le
témoignage des jeunes mineurs huis clos
partiel alors dehors on attend
s'interroge on imagine seul le tracteur
du voisin vient perturber cette
méditation au premier étage de la
bergerie deux témoins prennent leur mal
en patience
dans la salle l'ambiance est grave tendu
kevin 16 ans est oppressé gêné ces mots
sont mesurés mais empreint de douleurs
de souffrance qu'il confie sa honte de
ce qui lui est arrivé je sais que je ne
suis pas tout seul dit il
kevin a du mal raconté ce mercredi
après-midi de 1994 au domicile du curé
l'abbé morel se saisit de son micro et
appelle le mineur par son prénom kevin
ce n'est pas une prière
c'est une supplique pour que l'enfant
n'en dise pas plus mais l'adolescent
continue à voix basse il dit seulement
l'abbé m'a violée un an plus tard la
baie par aux états unis avec cap garçons
parmi lesquels florent new york
washington san francisco las vegas le
paradis la découverte du nouveau monde
mais c'est à orlando que florent
découvre l'enfer durant deux nuits
consécutives
il subit les assauts du prêtre ce n'est
pas un récit réel la scène du viol est
totalement imaginaire les moeurs que
vous m'attribuez sont exécrables depuis
quatre jours la des maurels reste sur la
même ligne de défense en perdant en
conviction car depuis les mineurs ont
parlé demain les jurés devront se faire
une religion
la réduction du temps de travail dans la
fonction publique reste largement à
négocier le ministère de la fonction de
la fonction publique a fait savoir qu'il
n'y aurait pas d'accord cadre sur les 35
heures pour les fonctionnaires puisqu'un
seul syndicat la cfdt a paraphé le texte
proposé par le ministre il restera donc
aux différents ministères la tâche de
régler eux mêmes la réduction du temps
de travail aux portes à juliette beau
nathalie moisan et philippe deslandes
enseignants policiers ou infirmières ils
ont tous des horaires de travail
différent avec les 35 heures ces
différences ne sont pas près de
disparaître désormais chacune des trois
fonctions publiques etat hôpitaux ou
collectivités territoriales va négocier
séparément son aménagement du temps de
travail
l'accord cadre proposé il ya trois
semaines à l'ensemble des fonctionnaires
a été refusé par la quasi totalité des
syndicats est au coeur de ce refus il ya
une question centrale c'est celle de
l'emploi c'est à dire qu'on est dans une
situation où le gouvernement ne prend
aucun engagement et refuse la création
d'emplois alors même que l'objectif de
réduction de temps de travail c'est
aussi de faire face à cette question de
l'emploi
pourtant il ya eu de longues
négociations au cours des deux nuits
blanches au ministère de la fonction
publique emile zuccarelli avait cédé sur
plusieurs fronts notamment le
remplacement de tous les départs en
retraite d'ici 2000 fois au final seule
la cfdt signera ce texte une sinécure
théoriquement suffisante pour appliquer
un accord 35 heures mais le ministre ne
veut pas s'en contenter
il préfère l'ouverture de nouvelles
négociations dans chaque administration
et d'avoir cet accord qui vaut à mon
sens et est utile pour donner de la
cohérence à la démarche ultérieure
c'était de la discussion ministère par
ministère hôpital par hôpital commune
par commune
on va aller directement cette discussion
de concentrer dès demain les
hospitaliers seront à nouveau dans la
ruche pour certains fonctionnaires des
négociations sur l'aménagement du temps
de travail vont s'ajouter à d'autres
revendications comme des moyens
supplémentaires de meilleures conditions
de travail
un nouveau cas de vache folle dans les
côtes d'armor cela fait huit ans en
france depuis le début de l'année puis
un premier cas de vache folle
enregistrées au danemark cette actualité
fait partie de toutes les conversations
actuellement en cours au salon de
l'agriculture à paris
du coup les éleveurs et les exploitants
en général affirme pratiquer
l'agriculture raisonnée et mettre
l'accent sur la qualité la sécurité des
aliments ce sujet faut-il ou non
interdire les farines animales
ces farines qui permettent de nourrir le
bétail en important assure plus de
protéines les farines animales rentrer
dans l'alimentation des poulets des
ports industriels et des poissons
d'élevage leur suppression ne réglerait
pas tout voyez-les enquête d'eric masi
et nadine piqueur danse étudie tonnes de
carcasses de boeufs
nous sommes à la sariat le plus gros
fabricants européens de farine animale
ici c'est un ballet incessant de camions
qui livrent ce qui reste des bovins
d'épouser des ports après l'abattoir en
france il se récupèrent chaque année
2,25 millions de tonnes de ces
sous-produits un vrai gisement de
matières premières qui une fois
transformés en grèce où farine trouvera
une utilisation même dans la vie de tous
les jours
alors nous avons les farines le viande
qui rentrent dans la composition des
aliments forts et volailles de même que
la graisse animale
nous avons aussi le suif de qualité
alimentation humaine également utilisés
en cosmétique ayant savonnerie mais
depuis l'histoire de la vache folle ces
farines et c'est grèce sont sur la
sellette
faut-il oui ou non les supprimer à la
sariat on affirme que toutes les
précautions sont prises et qu'il n'y a
plus de risque et que ce serait se
priver d'un aliment à bas prix est
extrêmement riche pour les élevages
industriels les porcs et les volailles
n'ont aucune raison de se priver d'une
ressource qui est essentiel pour eux et
à partir de vent ont interdit ce produit
on va dire dire quasiment toutes les
matières premières parce qu'elles
présenteront tous un risque à quelques
dates de quelle que nature que ce soit
donc je ne crois pas que ce soit la
bonne solution d'éliminer l'héparine de
l'alimentation des porcs et des
volailles
dijon cours vétérinaire de terrain a
connu des cas de vache folle selon lui
la traçabilité de la filière n'est pas
si sûr des vaches peuvent encore être
contaminés par des farines destiné au
port aux volailles et c'est pour cela
qu'il faut les interdire
maintenant le problème d'apple même
qu'avec des ogm est ce que c'est
dangereux ou pas dangereux appartements
les consommateurs ne veulent pas je
pense qu'il est temps de prendre des
décisions et par contre il faudra savoir
s'il faut savoir moi je vais pas j'ai un
avis personnel qui représente pas celui
de tous les vétérinaires ceci n'engage
que moi mais il faut savoir ce qu'on
fera de ces farines animales
la solution n'est pas simple interdire
les farines animales obligerait en était
à détruire systématiquement ces millions
de tonnes de déchets d'animaux puis de
les remplacer par des protéines comme le
soja américain qui lui est transgénique
coût de l'opération 3 milliards de
francs par an un chiffre qui fait
réfléchir les politiques
un jour béni paraît-il que ce lundi 28
février pour les amis des chiens et des
chats ou autres animaux familiers
destiné à franchir la manche pour vivre
dans les foyers de sa gracieuse majesté
la quarantaine imposée depuis un siècle
tous ceux qui n'y au lait à bois est
abolie donc par les anglais donc benoît
duquesne et steve rosenblum dont je
tiens à saluer la conscience
professionnelle se sont mis dans la peau
de ces chers compagnons pour nous faire
vivre ce lundi historique
c'est pas pour se vanter mais avec mes
collègues on n'était pas peu fier ce
midi à l'arrivée en l'angleterre
toutes ces caméras tous ces photographes
rien que pour nous on a été accueillis
comme des stars le dj for dogs ce qu'il
disait le jour j des chiens on le
méritait faut dire parce que avant d'en
arriver là il a fallu passer par ici
chez ce type au vraiment méchant mais
qui nous a fait une de ces piqûres pour
me mettre une puce sous la peau comme si
on en avait pas déjà assez
et puis il a fallu retourner plusieurs
fois faire un vaccin contre la rage des
tests sanguins des traitements contre
les puces les nôtres cette fois ça a
pris six mois mais on nous a dit c'est
ça ou la quarantaine ya pas photo mais
hier alors hier c'était vachement bien
on s'est tous retrouvés du ski me
désister là et les autres ils nous
avaient organisé une de ces petites
parties dans un hôtel
rien pour nous alors il y avait bien sûr
lady frais thouels qui arrêtait pas de
parler mais il faut dire qu'elle s'est
beaucoup battu pour supprimer la
quarantaine alors nous on n'a trop rien
dit c'était un peu son jour aussi et
puis ce matin là ça a été la phonie il
en avait tous après non les contrôleurs
d'eurotunnel nos maîtres les
journalistes ils voulaient vérifier si
la puce était toujours là comme si on
l'avait enlevée enfin dans l'ensemble on
s'est plutôt bien tenu on leur a montré
nos passeports tout neuf
et quand ils ont eu fini avec leurs
photos on a pu enfin monté sur le
flotteur
alors là le châtel il faut dire que
c'est pas très mal parce que nous on
n'avait pas le droit de sortir se
dégourdir les pattes
nos maîtres 6 mai le mieux le mieux ça a
été cette après midi à l'ombre dans hyde
park
quand on a dit aux copains d'où on
venait ils nous ont pris pour des
frimeurs normal ils sont jamais sortis
de chez eux
quel talent ce week-end sport rugby
cette discipline viril mais correct
sport de voyous pratiqué par des
gentlemen du temps est peut-être devenu
trop dur
du moins peut-on penser en
comptabilisant sept blessés parmi les
internationaux du quinze de france dont
l'entraîneur bernard laporte a besoin en
vue du prochain match samedi prochain à
edimbourg face à l'ecosse les deux
derniers blessés sont richard dourthe et
stéphane glace on est donc entre la
rubrique sportive et la rubrique santé
avec l'examen de christophe duchiron
julien riche en attendant elle de
rinxent passe les saisons les tournois
de cinq à six nations dans le rugby de
france dix professionnels tout change
rien ne change aux gros mots toujours
pas grand rebelles calendrier
récupération blessure ne tirez pas sur
le quinze de france c'est une ambulance
le genou de la maison le mollet de
bénesse les adducteurs de penauille de
galtier la cheville de glace la pommette
de l'un et la déchirure de l'autre en
attendant des nouvelles de la cuisse de
brouzet et de l'épaule de dal maso au
rendez-vous des gueules cassées c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui il ya un problème
quelque part de blessures et croyez moi
ce sera certainement pas finie
l'avenir la venue on dira que je que
j'ai raison et qu'il y aura encore des
blessés parce que ce n'est pas que pour
certains ça fait deux ans de compétition
non stop sans tarder à kas la coupe du
monde et le tournoi des six nations
juste le championnat de france l'us la
coupe d'europe plus tout l'entraînement
ça suppose avec les bleus ou avec son
club difficile de résister aux cadences
infernales
la faute au calendrier c'est par jour du
calendrier résulte de deux logiques
différentes des logiques des clubs d'un
côté qui veulent vivre très longtemps de
leur compétition et la logique
internationale qui veut au contraire
préparer les joueurs dans un laps de
temps très court sur très peu de
rencontres
il faut donc faire cohabiter ces deux
logiques facile à dire pas facile à
faire les français jouent trop c'est un
set mais les anglais qui nous ont battus
récemment joue presque autant à ce jour
ils n'ont pas de blessés à déplorer
alors que chez nous c'est l'hécatombe
c'est vrai qu'au fur et à mesure on
change des choses on modifie des
tactiles qu'ont les joueurs changent de
poste d'autres intègrent logo pour
dernier moment c'est pas évident un jour
viendra mais quand ou le rugbyman
français comme le salarié tricolore
passera aux 35 heures
joie paix bonheur et bonne humeur le
rugbyman français sera champion du
nombre
un jour peut-être jusqu'au 13 mai
prochain à paris à la maison de la
culture du japon pour la première fois
une exposition propose des sculptures de
papier 250 figurines d'une hauteur de 40
cm chacune environ ont été réalisés pour
évoquer l'un des chefs-d'oeuvre de la
littérature japonaise du moyen-âge le
récit de l'épopée des ics
c'est spectaculaire est fragile car ce
sont des pliages mais ce sont aussi
toute une histoire où l'on retrouve les
guerrier samouraï présentation daniel
wolfromm et bernard ont fleix l'épopée
d'eric et si l'on osait on comparerait
ce chef-d'oeuvre de la littérature
japonaise à la chanson de rolland le
récit a été colportée par des moines
aveugle avant d'être ixe siècle après
siècle
ils ont psalmodié cette histoire
terrible la lutte implacable de deux
clans aristocratique avec pour fondement
ce principe rien n'est permanent à rien
et constant et c'est une conception
boutique qui traverse toute la durée de
l'histoire de l'épopée d'eric et c'est
ce que raconte ce mois
c'est aussi ce qui évoque ses figurines
de papier 250 personnages acteurs des
principaux moments de l'épopée complot
amour trahison récits guerriers
finalement le clan tout-puissant d'eric
et va déchoir après un ultime combat
perdu en 185 le papier japonais
traditionnel blanc écru a une texture
particulière depuis une vingtaine
d'années il sert de matériau à cet
artiste artisan des figurines c'est
compliqué voici en tramway jusqu'à
signer ce cas la grande difficulté de
l'emploi du papier japonais c'est qu'on
fait tout en un coup si vous faites
apparaître le moindre pli la moindre
ride le papier va se briser
ce n'est pas l'effet que vous voulez
obtenir de toute façon vous n'aurez pas
d'autre chance ces papiers ne peut être
utilisé qu'une seule fois à l'issue du
récit le clan d'eric et quitte la
capitale qui auto pour un exil sans fin
car selon la doctrine bouddhique l'homme
puissant ne peut se soustraire au déclin
à l'image du coquelicot si flamboyant et
si fragile à la fois sa position
jusqu'au 13 mai la maison de la culture
du japon par qui nous arrivons à la fin
de cette émission je rappelle
l'actualité une réunion
interministérielle à nantes avec 5
milliards de francs dont un des sept
années 2000 d'être supplémentaires
annoncées par le gouvernement pour
effacer les dégâts de la tempête et ceux
de la marée noire cette annonce faite
aujourd'hui à nantes donc par lionel
jospin
la météo dans quelques instants si
patrice drevet et puis ensuite je
recommande l'enfant des termes non d'un
téléfilm des vernis hermans avec jean
yanne puis de magazines argent public à
22h30 qui vous sera présenté par sylvain
la table avec comme invité bernard pivot
amis ni l'autre et florence du propre le
dernier journal suivi de l'entretien
d'alain duhamel avec simone veil ce
demain 7 h 50 dans les 4 vérités
gérard morin recevra jean tiberi fils
puis à 13h ici même carole gaessler et
rachid arhab à demain 21 rebonds soir
merci